all right i smell heat yes we're going
to have plenty of that again today
looking out over the city starting out
with sunshine temperatures are warm boy
we couldn't get below 80 degrees
anywhere inside the valley this morning
88 on the strip 89 at green valley and
henderson and up in centennial hills 85
red rocks at 80 degrees mountains edge
86 looking for a hot date 107 today
103 is the average for our last couple
of days of june sunset tonight at 802.
here are your headlines extra hot
temperatures hang on for the next couple
of days and humid as well some of that
monsoon moisture is just kind of trapped
underneath this ridge of high pressure
so hot and sticky but we do have a very
slight chance of some thunderstorms in
the afternoon today and tomorrow we'll
get some breezy winds though tomorrow
into thursday with a cold front passing
through and that will take a little edge
off the heat we might even be down to
around 100 degrees by july 4th so there
is a slight cooling trend headed into
the independence day weekend here's the
cold front otherwise high pressure is
sitting over us and that is what's
keeping the temperatures extra warm we
were looking for a few maybe pop-up
thunderstorms especially over the
mountains yesterday and we could see
just a little return on the radar a
couple of cells that popped up in mohave
county but really nothing for clark
county still looking for about a 20
percent chance of thunderstorms this
afternoon up at mount charleston with a
high of 80 degrees and there's about a
10 chance we might see some lightning
here's some thunder get some gusty winds
out at the lake at 108 and you know if
you see lightning out at lake mead you
got to get off the water get safely
somewhere inside your vehicle and that's
a hard topped vehicle 107 for the valley
and again that very slight chance of
afternoon thunderstorms into the early
evening hours today and tomorrow and
some breezy southerly winds on thursday
those are stronger winds and then you
can see the temperatures just trend down
for the weekend as we head into july 103
104 but even down to about 100 for
monday